the town of Donegal in Northwest Ireland
is a popular tourist destination there's
much to see like donegal castle and the
nearby old castle bar and restaurant in
the heart of town here they serve up
Irish specialties the fish and shellfish
arrive fresh from the harbour head chef
david harrington gives us traditional
dishes a modern twist a traditional
Irish food is a lot of slow cooking and
shoes and we do pies the recipes
basically come from generation to
generation farmers housewives the
restaurant has been a fixture in Donegal
for over 150 years and is among the best
in town one of the favorite dishes here
is seafood pie baked according to an old
family recipe
[Music]
c 4 pi is it's comfort food and it's
it's one of those warm dishes you have
on a nice cold evening naturally the
main ingredient is fish preferably
salmon and Cod then comes the shellfish
a variety of vegetables cream parsley
and butter
first finely chopped vegetables are
sauteed in olive oil then they're doused
in white wine and light cream is added
reduce it down for two minutes
and now I'm going to add the smoked
salmon Cod and smoked collie because the
small Coley gives it a really nice smoky
flavor and the salmon is nice and fresh
and then it holds well in a in a pie it
doesn't crumble up too much and cards is
a nice flaky fish next the muscles and
prawns are sturdy in you could add
another kind of fish instead like pike
sea bream or ocean perch fresh catch is
delivered daily most fishermen set out
from the harbor in nearby Killybegs
bound for the Atlantic Smith Campbell's
been a fisherman for over 30 years
general angling we go out we catch
mackerel for bait fish and after that
then we go and fish for Pollock with
some very fine Paula also called for his
seafood pie david harrington mashes boil
potatoes with butter milk and green
onions into the potato puree
harrington loves to cook in his youth he
copied his grandmother's recipes it's
important for me to use new ideas and
cooking different products and
experimenting with local products and
coming up with the best recipes I can
and to go good consistency and make sure
that everything goes on the plate
perfectly and customers are happy now
the fish and vegetable mixture is
spooned into an ovenproof dish then
comes the potato puree and to top it off
grated cheddar cheese which gives the
pie its crunchy golden crust then
everything is browned in the oven for
around 20 minutes david harrington
serves his seafood pie with some
vegetables sautéed in butter broccoli
carrots and potatoes work well
and then this classic Irish dish is done
you have your vegetables and your mashed
potatoes and your fish and all in one
and it's a meal in a tough seafood pie
an Irish dish perfect for cold winter
days
[Music]